The way we found out about this is, well,
people were suspicious for a long time.
Like I said in 2007, two Microsoft
researchers already pointed out that if
somebody had known a relation between
these two solutions then they would be
able to crack the algorithm. But we
couldn't know for sure.
So I think some red flags were raised
and people were concerned but we didn't
know whether, you know, this was happening
or not but in September the Guardian and
the New York Times published reports in
which they - relying on the information
provided by Snowden - they confirmed that
indeed that's what happened. In some ways
it seems that the NSA was aware of the
relation between the two and that was
one of the tools inside of their
arsenal, in terms of arsenal of you know
being able to eavesdrop into and to
decrypt what people believed was
encrypted, safely encrypted information.
However, I think that if once people are
aware of this and they start actively
searching for that relation they may be
able to find it. And that's what I think
poses the greatest danger here; that once
you create sort of a backdoor, it's
almost like you have a door but you make
a little hole to let your dog in.
But you say, okay, well only
the dog will be
able to get in but nobody else. But then
next thing you know the cats going
coming in, you know the mice are
coming in and all kinds of other animals.
How do you prevent that? And and also the
problem is if you don't tell anyone that
people think that's bulletproof, the door
is bulletproof and nobody can get in.
And then turns out that there is
actually a hole. So that creates a
problem and that's an issue. So what we
have here is very sophisticated
mathematics being used for encryption.
And the problem is that mathematics can
be used for good but also for ill and
it can be misused. And these formulas
are powerful and they can help us in our
daily lives, they can simplify things,
they can make things- they can encrypt
things and so on. But there is also
opportunity to for misuse, and I think
that more people should be aware of how
these things are done,
what exactly goes in, and I think that if
we are more aware of this maybe we will
be able to have some safeguards and to
prevent these formulas, this mathematical
equations, from being misused.
- (Brady: One last)
(thing: I know you're just a lowly)
(mathematician and I'm just a lowly guy)
(with a camera; but this seems)
(extraordinary that companies were using)
(this- something they were being)
(spoon-fed by the government, almost)
(without question. That makes them seem)
(stupid that they used it.)
- Well I guess
there is a lot of sort of a finger
pointing and second-guessing
going on right now.
We were- there were reports that some
companies which were using this
algorithms actually advised their clients
to stop using them, so that was a huge
embarrassment for them I imagine. And I
think these revelations, they kind of
makes make us question the whole set up
now because there were certain things
that people took for granted and now we
are we have to re-evaluate this. And maybe
also we have to create some mathematics
which would be such that no one would be
able to misuse it in such a- in such a
sort of obvious way. So be kind of a
kind of mathematics which is just set up
in such a way that even if you wanted to
use it it wouldn't be possible. And I
think now maybe we should work more in
this direction.
- (I know this is serious)
(and there are a lot of people
who are very upset)
(about what happened;
but on a purely just)
(entertainment level, isn't
this cool that)
(mathematics is being used in this kind)
(of James Bond spying kind of way?)
- No I agree;
because you know people always ask me,
you're a mathematician so what do you do?
Like how is it relevant to the real
world? Well now I can just point them to
this and say look: US government talks
about elliptic curves. The National
Security Agency was using elliptic
curves. So these are not esoteric
objects anymore, this is something that
you use in your daily life. And so that's
very interesting and I think that if
anyone is not conv- if there's anyone
who's not convinced that mathematics is
playing a larger and larger role in this
wor- in this brave new world I think they
should be convinced now.